what is going on reject nation we're
gonna watch my friends over at new
rockstars one division
episode three their easter eggs and
breakdown video when the episode one and
two came out there was other stuff we
were covering that weekend
i kid you not there were like a
gazillion comments of people people
hitting him up on twitter were like
where's your reaction to the new rocks
and this
rarely happens for things that are not
trailer related
and i was like i'm sorry there's other
stuff to cover right now but for all
those people who were demanding that we
continue on
with the reactions to these new
rockstars breakdowns
thank you i mean even zach and eric
encourage our reactions as
zach is the producer new rockstars and
eric voss of course encourage our
reactions as well we must continue them
absolutely so everyone who is getting
mad at us for not putting it up
you better be you better be viewing this
video watching right now
right now at least right now let's talk
about it
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of one
division episode three
an episode that spoiler warning confirms
wanda envisions beybase as
billy kaplan and tommy shepard future
young avengers wiccan and speed all
while getting agonizingly closer to
revealing what the hell is going on in
west view so i'm going to comb through
this episode
some clues and details that you might
have missed after episodes based on the
dick van dyke show and bewitched episode
three's opening titles mixing influences
from 70s sitcoms
the brady bunch with a three by three
grid on the title of
three's company with the bike writing
and the music sounds like the partridge
family theme not the come on get happy
featured in ant-man the wasp but the
theme from the first season
that's muted in this video
there's sound what do you mean
and once again hexagons despite
all the other aesthetics updating
through the decades this geometric
formation keeps coming back
oh yeah sure not every hexagon you see
in the mcu is related hexagons are
common shapes that show up everywhere
the wormhole grid of the mcu the barrier
of wakanda
nothing is by accident no we are
probably not going to see the iron man 3
organization
in the same series general viewers are
trying to get to know what sword is
one dormant initiative per show people
but within one division
episode there could be a connection
amongst the hexagons we see in this
series
i mean probably or that honeycomb hive
west view theory
or simply juana's chaos magic often
being called hex
magic in the opening on them that's
probably it
it's everywhere oddly a 2013 title in a
70s setting now there could be a
parallel between wand division and the
wizard of oz this series also has
multiple witches
a tin man and seems to be all about
smoke and mirror i never thought about
that interesting oh yeah who's currently
directing elizabeth
i mean you see i just love stuff like
that that when eric says those things
because i'm like
that's probably all not really linked
but it's cool
it's a nice easter egg threads i see how
you got there
yeah that makes sure why not it's
connected your kevin bacon six degree
separation thank you
six degrees of easter eggs agnes once
again has her pendant which appears to
show
three figures some are saying this could
be connected to the three witches of
macbeth
i'm not sure though there's definitely a
taller one that holds something above
these smaller ones maybe a clue that
wanda's children are being kind of
marionetted by another
entity actually strings vision with that
same finger guns gesture that he did
last episode
interestingly herb does do a lot of
puppy with agnes this episode
and she did that same pew pew gesture to
the mailman last episode
stick him up oh don't shoot i'm just a
messenger
this is a green and yellow color
costuming scheme which he will show up
wearing later this series and you'll
notice when vision later swings with
wanda you can briefly see paul bettany's
flesh arm under his sleeve
pigeon reads this red light script
supervisor pregnancy the
psychological experience by libby and
arthur coleman
it looks super worn down which is a bit
odd because it was first published in
1973
this sitcom is set in the library book
should not be that beaten up
some say that shadowy figure on the
front looks like this though others say
it kind of looks like mysterio
if you do think about it in spider-man 3
photos is being made into this
conspiracy murder with
a bunch of other flyers for missing
children
and mysterio illusions absolutely this
could all be one big illusion and
mephisto
also likely yeah
maybe maybe they're too good it's hard
to outsmart
derek set is modeled on the living room
the rock wall the stairs of the brady
home
wanda's hair is even fashioned like
marsha brady long straight and parted
down the middle careful wanda it is the
70s bundy is still on the loose
vision oh god i mean practically
overnight i mean
how did this happen that sharp leg
squeeze we do start to see this episode
a diverging of wandas and visions
motives and their levels of cognition
wanda is far more concerned with hiding
their superhero natures and
nesting while vision seems like he's on
that same page but
he totally publicly reveals his powers
in his pursuit
to figure out what the hell is going on
something that by the end of the episode
wanda doesn't seem to care that much
about
dr nielsen is kind of an idiot we let
the little ladies keep tabs on their
growing babies with fruit
makes it simple for them son of a [ __ ]
now in this
comparison he says at seven months it's
the size of a pineapple
the fruit we later see wanda carving up
maybe the same pineapple agnes gave them
an episode one
it's like the whole time
now the doctor's headed out on vacation
bermuda baby
oh i love how intertwined everything is
that is so
neat the pineapple there's no way to
tell if that's the same pineapple is
there i am
wait i'm literally wasting my guess
script super
easily the worst department unnecessary
pause during reaction i've ever done in
my life
it's okay there are a lot of great
classic pineapples and popular cultures
we've got
several more minutes to go here
interesting destination associated with
the bermuda triangle aka the devil's
triangle
where various vessels over the years
have gone missing not
unlike the sword toy helicopter that
suddenly appeared in west view after
perhaps vanishing from the outside world
as a life-size
aircraft west view here could be that's
so cool the hexagon the devil's hexagon
with a dark agenda too to use the
doctor's words make a bermuda baby
bermuda baby meanwhile herb is glitching
[Music]
this tells us herb isn't playing a part
actively to deceive them
but under a kind of spell that is
causing them to malfunction like this
it's a lot like the simulated reality
and rick and morty which also similarly
glitches
my man and just the time he was outside
juana's pregnancy jumps to five months
judging by the papaya he holds beside
her womb like that b-bean toaster and
the ticking striker watch
time's getting faster and faster it
isn't advancing logarithmically it's a
curved exponential acceleration in the
nursery wanda eats oranges
probably the orange that dropped off the
table in the previous scene orange
slices are kind of a thing in the mcu
scott lang mentioned them as a recharge
food after growing in civil war
does anyone have any orange slices in
this same orange slices showed back up
again
closely but they're painting with sensor
paint universe of color which is an odd
to jerry simpson
a marvel studio storyboard artist for
one division doctor stranger versus how
neat
now wanda's butterfly mobile real easter
egg right there it's kind of fluttery
oh did i do that i didn't need to did i
do that wanda the 80s sitcom herbal
verses until next week
also wanda is verbalizing here how she
accidentally changes the world and
brings beans to
life with just words blapped out
something that could happen with
jose mutants but instead of no more
mutants
let there be mutants babies
that's the character turn i want
i mean that's the theory that i had uh
everything
i think a lot of us had that theory
ultimately is that they would do a flip
road because the one division show isn't
most of marvel mcu is not just like
let's just do exactly the comics they
deviate a lot and they do their
own thing and wanda vision is certainly
no exception to it all
right but i would love that flipper room
that instead of
ending on no more mutants like how it
did in the comic it uses to flip it
around in the mcu which
actually kind of honors the reality
vending warping even more in a meta kind
of way
absolutely by doing that for like oh in
the comics we did this but by adapting
the comics we did the opposite thing but
it
would have kind of a weird similar
effect to a certain extent you know what
i mean
mirror dovetailing yeah it'd be neat if
you need
everything i tried saying in 18
sentences you said in one i'm proud of
you
that's why i'm here billy well i was
thinking tommy just a
nice classic all-american name ah
confirmed as we've speculated for the
past year
wanda's children are indeed billy kaplan
and tommy shepherd
the marvel mutants and young avengers
wiccan and speed respectively their
story in the marvel comics is a little
confusing
see when wanda first has her kids in the
comics they aren't really given full
identities yet they are just kind of
revealed to be illusory pieces of
mephisto's soul and then are later being
assembled into mephisto
agatha wipes her memory but then later
wanda tries to re-materialize these kids
in house of
m and around this era in comics wiccan
and speed are introduced as
young avengers and then they're kind of
connected back as wanda's mutant
children via that mephisto link
i know i know huh is simplifying this
one division is a kind of prelude to
wanda's reality
flipping and house of m setting up
future young avengers in the marvel
cinematic universe
kids who will team up with kate bishop
from the upcoming hawkeye series cassie
lang from the ant-man the wasp quantum
mania movie
and others vision quotes yeah all the
world's a stage all the men and women
many players
ah this is the famous seven ages of man
monologue from as you'd like it it's an
extended metaphor comparing the life of
a person to a theatrical performance
paralleling the central conceit of one
division in which
these avengers lives are a kind of
performative scripted routine that's
in front of an audience the kitchen soap
is labeled toy
how how do you shakespeare was all about
those comments i was just
like um what is the research like on
these videos
lately when we were doing this pause
react thing i try to
provide like additional commentary on
top of it
and every time we do new rock stars i'm
just like
you're just sitting here having your
mind at the point where all i'm doing is
showing their videos
i'm just sitting here yeah this is a
learn along this isn't even really a
reaction this is edutainment
at its finest are you guys literally
scrubbing this frame by framing how
quickly you guys got this assembled
you're just like
well i know what that book is is this is
you eric who's putting this all together
i mean that is a pretty a pretty famous
passage but i i never stopped to think
about how perfectly
most people won't do most people won't
do it and they have to go and find that
pass to make sure you're nailing it
right yeah that's true it's very
impressive and it does mirror that and
that's what i mean man
you can't just say the hexagons are just
in normal shape it's all tied in
it's all tied in somewhere for you
specific routine that's in front of an
audience
the kitchen soap is labeled koi maybe
not to this whole reality
quirky marks meanwhile over at the
chances phil reads the newspaper with
the headline
two fire hydrants added on main street
jessica actually yesterday pointed out
how the fold makes it look like the
hydrangea the lamp is what i'm looking
at it's got these two
cherubs on it remember dottie is for the
children
children that are now in west view as
wanda's twin
babies billy and tommy then this moment
i think something's wrong here
yes i know what you mean the truth is
we are in uncharted yes this is an
intentional editing choice the music
changes from dead
serious scoring to cutesy sitcom crap
it's kind of like when wanda said
no and rewind west view it's the same
kind of language of video editing
it looks as though wanda again is the
one doing it notice her right before the
jump looks as
if side to side as if to say no oh
vision says we are in uncharted waters
much like the uncharted waters within
the bermuda triangle
let's make this a thing maybe everything
we are seeing on the inside of this
reality
is the kind of sitcom feed that wanda is
projecting out on local airwaves
that's how sword is monitoring her and
why wanda can cover up the cracks in the
form of this sort of awkward editing now
in the commercial
wait wait i'm a little confused thank
you for pausing
is he saying he's admitting it in his
sitcom feed well
so like other people can be watching
this right right
other people can watch this show yeah
like maybe wanda
whatever's happening with her sort of
emitting this experience
through the lens of this sitcom and
maybe somehow telepathically they were
able to tap into that through the
airwaves or something like that yeah
oh and that's what it would explain this
yeah
post credit uh not po the
season premiere finale yeah what am i
trying to say for the final moments of
the season the first
season first episode the the credits
within the show
clearly i was out of time
wow okay like maybe this is the strange
way wanda's mind is packaged this
terrible way to hide wanda
you're gonna call more attention people
are gonna be tuning in
who else is tuning in the sword who who
in this marvel world is just a regular
human here's this like
what's this weird show on tv we gotta be
a couple like conspiracy nuts or
something living in this universe who
have some kind of
antenna that's gonna happen because uh
yeah that is an
interesting point i do hope by the end
of this series they explain why it's
sitcoms wanda better while she was
having a torturous life
have some thing imbued in her oh growing
up my escape was
television sitcom at the most intense
finale moment there will be a fade to
white and then we'll just see her and
pietro watching
you know bewitched yeah and roseanne
that's what raised us
and why wanda can cover up the cracks in
the form of this sort of awkward editing
now in the commercial the boy i'll also
say one is the best
person to be a showrunner she stars in
it she edits
she does the production design she
writes she's got all the stories
she even does a lot of the stuff i mean
look at the magic show scene set dress
all the cinematography freaking lighting
oh my god
effects all the fruit the the catering
of my
like she is the best show
boy in the background is played by
wesley kimmel nephew to jimmy kimmel who
in a pre-season interview with paul
benton nepotism blue by objecting not
being invited to the prince and family
studio taping
i think it was a friends and family kind
of
friends and family i'm an employer and
of course the product is
hydra soak with the hydra logo on the
design pattern this is actually a
fascinating nod to another marvel tv
series agents of shield
which coulson in an episode when he was
in a simulation called the framework
oh god that controlled people's minds
i figured it out a long time ago if it
wasn't for the mind control soap yeah
wait what that blue soap everyone uses
hydra loads it up with chemicals
it seeps into our bloodstream and plants
false memories into our brains
they want us to believe this is a
magical place but don't worry
i'm clear i make my own soap now
i wish you could talk about that i
literally
just that is such a big giveaway i just
got to the episode where they all go
into the framework such a nifty easter
egg
oh well that sounds i'm excited john
does
uh reaction watch alongs for ages shield
on patreon
and so apparently that's that's what
he's saying damn
that is that is a hell of an easter egg
then
like they just explained the [ __ ] out of
that bar of soap right there
hey no this is great because like next
week or the week after i'm gonna get the
full breakdown on this
and they're also honoring agents to
shield the show that that's kind of
crazy that among at least fans
yeah is the one that still is gleaning
for respect even the
mcu marvel the one where it seemed like
that's what
feige approved and then and wanted
nothing to do with it afterwards because
that's the one
netflix shows can can come back in some
form
so can shield wow they really explained
that fiercely theory by coulson and i'm
not sure if westview is the exact same
thing as that agents of shield framework
but i do still love this parallel
because
obviously wanda is in the same kind of
fictitious reality
and these commercials are giving us lots
of callbacks to her past
as a hydra lab rat find the goddess
within
is an interesting tagline maybe
reflecting wanda's role as the goddess
of this pocket reality an emerging omega
level threat in the mcu
and like the hydra striker watch always
make time
and that stark toaster forget the past
focus on the future
it's kind of another call everything's
about time this goddess
also in marvel lore wanda sorcery kind
of comes from a curse from the demon god
chauthon
could be tied to that jessica brought up
the interesting theory that this could
be the greek goddess of witches
kate who wanda meets in the james
robinson scarlet witch 2016 solo series
now wanda comically tries to hide her
pregnancy from geraldine it's kind of a
meta nod to the way sitcoms will
awkwardly hide pregnant cast members
babies with props
i didn't pick up on it that's really
classic
actually and then for friends lisa
coutro got pregnant they worked i like
her better when they just work it into
the series somehow
but that is true though well they will
often try to hide it but that is
i just thought it was just a bit yeah
exactly yeah but that works that's cool
it's neat it tries to banish the stork
with this red
smoke much like the red smoke used by
the wicked witch of the west but the
smoke doesn't work
suggesting that wanda's not totally in
control of this reality
wand she needs more funding for her
television show yeah she's running out
of budget
nights and notice how one of the screen
has this deep demonic echo to it
i know yeah billy and tommy are born
actually if you think about it tommy
does come out first because he's speed
baby
dr nielsen decides to cancel his trip i
don't think we'll
get away after all small towns you know
so hard to escape
followed by vision catching agnes and
herb
did you lose power too oh sure did
but ralph looks better with the dark so
i'm not complaining you know it is
pretty much the same joke that we saw
with phil and dottie not very original
agnes is your shadow bound husband
really the grim reaper or mephisto
urban agnes casts doubt on geraldine
calling her an outsider
she's new to town brand new there's no
family
no husband no home she came here because
we're all
she came in because we're all what what
are you trying to tell me because we're
all stop it
ah sounds like herb was about to say
trapped or
we're all under a spell maybe even dead
i find agnes
it sounds like it could have been
anything
we're in a tight spot i thought he was
gonna say like i get to cut him off
at the beginning of this work then it's
just a whole lot of
fill in the blanks we're hungry we're
we're lost we're
uh dead no uh damn
we're worried no
oh but no you're right 100 yeah i
thought it was just attractive
too that's what i thought when i was
watching it this is reaction interesting
because she
clearly views geraldine slash monica as
a threat and once her gone
but she also desperately does not want
her to reveal to vision what is really
going on just yet
in fact her words stop it are exactly
what mrs hart said when she broke down
kind of like a skipper
stop it yes stop it
that's what's right and she seems to
exert some
control of her herb and the others in
the town to maintain that charade but
wait a minute though wait stop it is
also a thing
but they want things to stop but but but
it is a moment it is
it is a very i mean is the implication
that he's saying is is that
is he saying i get the part of the
mind bending uh controlling this reality
so was she controlling whoever
that person is you know the i'm you
can't find the footage now
but you know what i'm trying to say
harry rupp's character yeah yeah i was
like interrupting the character because
when that guy was choking
it was breaking the the the reality
that they were living in at the time of
that show so
yeah i'm still curious this character
said though like that character
i think there's actually something to it
that does seem specific yeah
some control over herb and the others in
the town to maintain that charade but
they need wanda to also want to stay
plugged in
using her desire for the children to
keep her happy meanwhile
sword and monica are a threat to that
illusion they want to end it they want
to break wanda free and free the people
this town
thus agnes is apprehension toward monica
and based on wanda turning on monica at
the end of this episode
looks like wanda's still drinking agnes
kool-aid for now
then wanda tells monica i'm a twin
i had a brother his name was pedro
pietro maximoff quicksilver he died in
sokovian age of ultron and juan is
tapping back into this past when she
sinks the sokovian lullaby and i love
how wanda's accent reverts when she says
pietro
and then monica thinking oh yeah that's
a good point the accent room i didn't
even notice that i thought it's just the
pronunciation of his name
it could also be there maybe she just
wants to honor those eastern european
roots by the way
says you know the eastern european
iterations like peter we live in
california
there's a lot of spanish-speaking folk
out here and a lot of the time you know
they they might just sound perfect
american accent
and then they start they might they'll
just say a name in spanish and like
oh i can't even say it yeah it's like
all the enunciates all
like culture personality shift like whoa
[Laughter]
and without it like i'm gonna say
quesadilla way different than i do
yeah i mean she has an american accent
now she did lose that yeah
and then monica thinking she has an inn
here tries to
connect with her he was killed by ultron
wasn't he
and this breaks wanda out of the trance
just briefly returning her to that
reality of being an avenger in that
whole mcu history but it's too
early wanda does not want that right now
and she sees that sword necklace and
connects it to the logo that she saw on
the helicopter toy on the beekeeper
she steps in threateningly and then
suddenly monica is
gone where's geraldine
oh she left honey
right he looks eerily calm kind of like
mia pharaoh at the end of rosemary's
baby
or that creepy boy at the end of the
twilight zone episode after he banished
the bad man
the aspect ratio widens out and we see
the exterior sword perimeter camp as
monica
crash lands outside to the monkey's
daydream believer which we talked about
in the earlier trailer breakdown in
these shots you can see the town welcome
site with
logos for various community groups
including the eagle club
and the community watch group i think
that's one vision join it's got this
eye logo whether sword or someone else
someone is
always watching west view hopefully
there is
a house visible from the outside join us
that west view was an actual town
established in the real world before
wanda's pocket reality
warped it into this sitcom oh no and
this is important good
job do not change on the outside
suggesting that whatever
wait wait we gotta slow that down it's a
great catch
so this place already exists yeah that's
the thing we were like questioning
literally we watched our reaction i was
questioning this whole thing but so
she took over a town and started rea and
warping it
i didn't i didn't think that would be
but you know it's good to always shoot
your shows on locations absolutely
absolutely it's production value
plus yes you got all these free extras
all this free talent
and plus you know it does well for the
town the community you know that you
need some help certainly they'll get
more people moving in
tourists that's how you do it there man
there you go you're making
tax breaks from the government for
shooting in west view
i did not even think about that but that
is
that is almost a pretty much solid
identifier for it she's messing with
this town and making their lives great
that's right making their lives a
television show damn you wanda
that's what you all wanted us to be
famous
world before wanda's pocket reality
warped it into the sitcom illusion
also note and this is important monica's
70s clothes do not change on the outside
suggesting that whatever changes wanda
makes on the inside of the pocket
reality
remain lasting changes to all of reality
in case one happens to say let there be
mutants
oh my one last detail i want to leave
you with in the closing credits of these
episodes you can briefly hear
among all the scoring whoa i love that
catch
i love that of her clothes and outfit
everything about monica changed
yeah yeah and that and so when she goes
back into the reality that oh oh and
then with the music i'm just
uh i am terribly repeating what he just
said
there's no point in me doing that i just
want to say i love it
but that's true right that is true yeah
that makes it i mean it means
whatever is in that reality can be
finite once you're out of there
unless they send her in with like a full
it's just
wardrobe of decade appropriate clothing
and color something not
in the closing credits of these episodes
you can briefly hear among all the
scoring
the sounds of a woman wailing inside
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was great that was amazing again
they are the kings there's a lot of
channels
out there that i respect that i love
that i really admire for their
incredible breakdowns
none so much as new rocks but really
none so much as them they
are i think they are the best at it
there's a lot that i really do love in
the suburbs that we've reacted to before
but damn did they blow my mind
specifically eric boss and eric boss
himself blow my mind
and kudos to the editors and they they
have shifted a lot of questions that we
had were actually well addressed here
with pretty solid theories
all right guys well subscribe to
rockstars you haven't done so already
thanks for watching
subscribe to us check out our wander
reaction we'll see you guys soon
[Music]